>> THIS HOLIDAY SEASON GIVE THE
GIFT OF NETFLIX, AND ENJOY
STREAMING SHOWS LIKE "STRANGER
THINGS," "THE CROWN," AND
"MAKING A MURDER."
AND IN 2019 WE'LL HAVE EVEN MORE
PROGRAMMING TO CHOOSE FROM
BECAUSE WE'VE GONE CRAZY!
THAT'S RIGHT.
WE'RE SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, AND MAKING EVERY SHOW
IN THE WORLD.
OUR GOAL IS THE ENDLESS SCROLL.
BY THE TIME YOU REACH THE BOTTOM
OF OUR MENU, THERE'S NEW SHOWS
AT THE TOP.
AND THUS, THE SINGULARITY WILL
BE ACHIEVED.
HOW WE DOING IT?
SIMPLE.
WE BUY EVERYTHING.
HERE'S A LOOK AT ONE OF OUR
ACTUAL PITCH MEETINGS.
>> SO THIS SHOW IS ABOUT A GIRL
NAMED JIMMY.
>> YES, HERE'S MONEY.
GO, MAKE IT.
MAKE IT!
>> WE'RE EVEN BUYING STUFF FROM
OURSELVES.
WE LOVE CLAIRE FOY AS
QUEEN ELIZABETH SO MUCH, WE'RE
SENDING HER BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL.
>> I'M IN OVER MY CROWN!
>> IT'S "SAVED BY THE CROWN."
>> WE'VE GOT SO MANY SHOWS --
EVEN WE HAVEN'T SEEN THEM ALL.
LIKE "KENNY MEAT DEPOT."
IT'S BEEN ON THREE SEASONS, AND
ONLY ONE WOMAN WATCHES IT.
>> HELLO, I'M RUTH AND I LOVE
"KENNY MEAT DEPOT."
>> THANKS, RUTH.
AND HEY, WE STILL GOT MOVIES.
THOUSANDS OF THEM.
12 OF WHICH YOU WANT TO WATCH.
>> WE EVEN MADE ALL THE FAKE
MOVIES FROM "ENTOURAGE."
"BETTY IAN," AND "QUEEN'S
BOULEVARD."
AND WE GOT REBOOTS.
LIKE OUR DARK TAKE ON "SABRINA,"
THEN YOU'LL LOVE OUR GRITTY
"FAMILY MATTERS" REBOOT.
>> OH, LALA MY PET, I LOVE YOU.
>> GET THE [ BLEEP ] OUT OF MY
HOUSE!
WHY DID I DO THAT?
>> BUT DON'T WORRY, WE ALSO GOT
THAT COMEDY, LIKE COMEDIANS IN
CARS GETTING COFFEE OR
LESLIE JONES IN A VAN GETTING
BATTERIES.
>> LET'S GO GET SOME DURACELL.
OH MAN, I THINK I HIT THAT DUDE
ON THE BIKE!
>> IT WILL TAKE 12 HUMAN
LIFETIMES TO WATCH ALL OF OUR
CONTENT.
>> SO START WATCHING NOW.
[ APPLAUSE ]